let's go next to jill from burbank
california jill you were on the air
jill from burbank california please
unmute yourself and then we'll be able
to hear you
uh can you hear me
yes
okay uh big fan um two things uh i
wanted to
talk about one was jesse lee peterson
it was fascinating to watch you debate
him
um
but
my point is that he doesn't think that
he's wrong after even
you you know confronted him
and
you know basically showed him that he's
uh he's in he doesn't know anything
about
uh his
stance right um
what do you think we should do
to people like that because
should we even engage because
uh
he's the biggest
example i think
for people
even after you
show them the facts and tell them
that he you know they have no sense
they go and they have a they have their
show and they have their own um
day-to-day
and they continue
yeah i don't think it's so much about
convincing jessie lee peterson it's more
is it worth doing
so that maybe people in the audience see
how quickly his assertions fall apart
and crumble um i don't go in thinking
the goal here is to convince jesse lee
peterson to change his mind it's let's
just show how silly and cartoonish his
entire perspective is you know so i
think it's just we have to manage what
the expectation is i wasn't i wasn't
trying to change his mind
right yeah
but
i mean you you had one person come back
and say oh i'm i'm a democrat now and
you know not a republican anymore which
is which is a good thing i think maybe
yeah people saw it and maybe they
changed their minds as a result of
seeing it for sure i think that's really
the goal it's for the audience rather
than for jessie lee peterson
but now in the tuesday election uh
you know that you know younkin won i
think it was
a few things like the crt which is not
you know taught anywhere but
they made made a boogeyman out of
nothing just like
trump did out of a
you know caravan is coming
and he tried to do it in the midterms as
well
um
but what do you think
like
why can't democrats also
make a boogeyman out of
something that republicans do
it's just not clear democrats would fall
for it like what would they what would
they do what would they do oh
republicans want to ban abortion well
it's like well most of them do it's not
you know what like what would you what
would the boogeyman be you know
anything like that yeah exactly like
abortion or um
you know our child care uh that we are
basically at
at the end of the list uh on
yeah it just doesn't seem to create so
many points it doesn't seem to create
the fear and anger
that
motivates these republicans to get out
and vote let me think about whether
there is such an issue it's an
interesting idea jill but i just don't
know if it would work let me think about
it
those are the two thank you uh keep on
doing what you're doing uh i'm gonna
switch from uh tcyd to you
my uh
twitch sub well thank you so much for
everything all right thanks jill
appreciate it there's jill from burbank
very very strongly presenting a number
of different arguments
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone but i left
my wallet somewhere i don't have my real
credit card on me i can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft
privacy is a totally free service and
you'll get five bucks to spend when you
go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video